I've got a twisted tale to tell you in
this video wordsmiths because the word I
want to talk about is
interwoven
interwoven it's an adjective and it
means twisted or joined together and it
has a a literal meaning like two fibers
woven into the same carpet but it also
has a figurative one like the strands of
two families joining together when their
children get
married let's talk about the word parts
here we've got
inter which means between or
among and interaction right is action
between two or more things an intercom
is a device that allows you to
communicate within a building or similar
and woven is the past tense form of to
weave weaving is when you make fabric
out of threads by inter inter
interlacing them on a machine called a
loom I was just in a fabric Workshop
here's a picture I took of a loom from
the other day the threads are under
tension and you plate them together and
if you do that enough times you have a
piece of fabric a weave in the noun form
is a hair extension or it can be the
pattern that you make by weaving
something let's weave these word Parts
into other words leaving weave aside for
now what are some words that you can
think of that use the prefix inter I'll
put on some music meet me back here in
10 seconds all right let's do it
[Music]
here are three that I came up with
interrelated an adjective that means two
things are related to one another right
there's a connection between them an
intersection a Crossroads where two
roads cut into each other that's that's
what sect means it's from sec to cut so
intersection intercept which is a verb
that means to catch something on its way
to somewhere else you can intercept a
ball and snatch it out of the air while
it's passing between two places or a spy
can intercept a secret message oh no
that spy has made a way with that top
secret
communic oh no he has disappeared let's
use interwoven in a few sentences here's
a literal
use in this pattern blue threads are
interwoven with pink right right if you
do this enough times you can sort of see
where plaid comes from the strands are
literally woven together but here's a
figurative use of the word the food
traditions of Italy and India are
interwoven in my dad's signature dish
pizza curry in this case it's Traditions
that have been Twisted together rather
than literal strands of thread curried
Pizza is a real thing by the way if
you've never had it and it's incredible
dip a piece of cheese pizza into SOG
paneer and thank me later listen
wordsmiths I'm just here to help in
matters food related and in matters word
related and you're just here because you
can learn anything David out